the Trump administration will appeal to
a federal judge later today for more
time to reunite young immigrant children
with their parents a court ruling last
month ordered the government to reunite
102 children under the age of five with
their families by tomorrow officials say
in all there are fewer than three
thousand undocumented immigrant children
currently in federal custody
Mireya Villarreal is on the border in El
Paso Texas amid the growing tensions
over the delayed reunification process
Matea good morning well good morning you
know the government has been doing DNA
testing to verify family connections and
still they can't do that fast enough
right now which is why they are asking
for that extension now we have seen a
number of reunification there's a
handful over the last few weeks but
people here in El Paso and around the
country are growing frustrated with what
they say is government inaction a crowd
in Louisville chased and shouted at
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
over the weekend who became the latest
target of protesters outrage as the
government struggles to reunite children
with their parents in one example
reported by The Associated Press
a one-year-old Honduran boy appeared
before an immigration judge in Phoenix
Friday he was reportedly granted a
voluntary departure order sending him
back to Honduras and his family a child
appearing in court without a government
appointed lawyer isn't is not a rarity
leak alert is the lead lawyer at the ACL
u--'s challenge to the Trump
administration's zero-tolerance policy
he says the government will likely
reunite less than half of the children
by tomorrow's deadline they started the
reunification process far too late and
only when the court forced them to do it
and they're also using an extremely
inefficient process this is one of the
busiest border crossings in the country
and while discussions play out in
Washington DC and in federal court
people living right here in El Paso say
they feel like they are stuck in the
middle someone's gonna have to develop
some intestinal fortitude up there and
do what's right irrespective of their
political leanings El Paso mayor de
margo calls the separation of families
inhumane and says it's the result of
decades of congressional inaction when
you don't treat the root problem it just
continues to fester and I think this
will continue to fester the federal
government has until July 26 to reunify
all of the older children the Department
of Justice said this morning that they
are eager to present their case their
progress to that federal court and they
have been working tirelessly to reunify
these families the ACLU though will
argue that they need stricter
instructions and oversight to make sure
they meet all of those future deadlines
Norah Maria great reporting there from
El Paso
once again you hear from local officials
this is a failure of the federal
government to address this issue it's
been building for years Congress has
been out to lunch
yeah the merit race a lot of good points
somebody's got to do intestinal
fortitude to do the right thing here
it's a big mess yeah is what it is